hey folks Chris waters here PAX East
2014 it's the final day and Danny you
have been talking to me about transistor
a game you got to play this weekend and
if you folks don't know this game
it's it's beautiful for one but I lay
the groundwork for these okay fine so
fashion was the game that supergiant
launched a couple years ago sheddeth
correct seven former GameSpot editor and
this is I will you know it's a sequel it
is very much in the same vein as bastion
is that an isometric and adventure game
that is heavily based on combat it's
mostly linear and combat is the key and
I was with pasturing which is a game
which had a relatively simplistic combat
system which sort of evolved and became
interesting as the game progressed yeah
transistors is a game where the combat
is is key to have engaged all right how
much have enjoyable the experience
action and is that the kind of thing you
can just like get a feel for during a
show floor demo there's so many of these
things you know it's it takes a little
while to get into it but you know it's
such a distinct combat system yep in
transistor well I guess I wonder if this
to do with Greg being part of the games
pressure all but those guys are real
good at making demos for so floors
really it's just as well because there's
the cue for that the line yeah it was
pretty big and yeah so it's real good
that the demo I played basically
introduced you with as the titular
character this lady who's got this
ridiculously big sword there is a voice
speaking to you and as it is in Bastion
kind of narrating the game and you start
off with one power they quickly reduce
the second one a third one and a fourth
one and what they also introduced is the
ability to stop time which then turns it
from a general action isometric hacking
slasher into a turn-based almost a
fighting game so it stops time you can
have a certain amount of like points you
can spend based on distance moves
and and the attacks you use or the
defensive mechanisms love one of the
ones I had locked was that was something
which got to the dash away really
quickly okay so you planned those s hit
right trigger again by Matt Matt Matt
BAM it already happens quick and then
you have to rely on the using those
exact same and moves just in the in
general time until your bar threat still
remains that's it yeah and that's the
thing that I think is good capturing a
lot of people's interest is the way that
it does transition from that hack and
slash to that planning that strategic
because you know there's some strategy
of how you you you're gonna go about the
action but when you're pausing to think
about it yeah it takes on a whole
different field and that's I think that
is a fair criticism the Basu perhaps is
that does the type of game where you can
run through it's just hitting everything
like there is a layer of strategy that
you can't employ but you don't
necessarily have to what happened when I
kind of had a Eureka moment when I hit
that for the first time I was like oh
this bomb thing this like AoE one would
actually work really well if I was in
that position but because now I can
actually see will you play these games
so much happening you are often just
involved in it unless you really take
time to try and plan something whereas
in this you can stop check it out you're
looking at like the areas of effect for
the shots you're looking at the angles
because just like Muhsin you were like
using the d-pad so like to see where
you're hitting in our stuff yeah so it
it it makes it more interesting and then
also you tend to employ those tactics
when you're not in the wheel the term
based mode as well like you bring it
back at like you're learning yeah that's
a cool sort of feedback loop yeah like
the tactics you use plan out
strategically then become part of your
active repertoire very cool well you
folks have been seeing at this game in
action here in this vid but Danny that
like to art style with something that's
super giant yeah I'm not so strong with
with Bastion
no this one you know you can see that
the through line of the general artistic
approach it looks very different yeah
yeah and Italy but it also looks
similarly gorgeous and sounds great like
for a really small team they have a very
high level of polish on the games they
create and transistors very much like
that as well so it sounds wonderful the
music the effect of that voice talking
in your head and and also shout out to
Greg the storytelling is as interesting
as it was in Bastion like again probably
tailored for this demo real good of
course with the reveals but yeah it's a
game this that I think perhaps for a lot
of people bashing was interesting
because of the story or because of the
graphics and whatnot
this has this as well but the combat is
immediately more engaging from the off
and which I think is gonna make a really
exciting when it comes out next month
yeah like May 20th next month
yeah PlayStation 4 and PC so we won't be
looking at it on show floors of expose
around the world anymore and you might
have to abandoned on internet videos
with too devilishly handsome people one
of whom has an out of control you go
that's
can figure that one out for yourself